[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
My guest today is
Pascal Jaillon, who
leads the developer
program at the startup Magnet.
Welcome on the show, Pascal.
PASCAL JAILLON: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: So could you
tell us a bit about Magnet--
what you guys are doing?
PASCAL JAILLON: Yeah.
Magnet offers developers
a suite of products
to build great
mobile applications,
meaning apps that have a great
experience online or offline.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So your customers
are not consumers
of apps-- individual users.
You are targeting
the developers.
That requires quite a different
kind of marketing, right?
How do you market
to these developers?
PASCAL JAILLON: We don't
really market to developers
as much as we start
conversations with them.
Developers nowadays have a lot
of choices in terms of product
to use.
And they need to see
that what you offer
will add value to their mobile
app, to their architecture,
to their development process,
or their operational process.
Long gone is the time when
management will actually
have a list of approved product
that developers will be using.
Now developers,
architects-- they
all have a lot of choices
of open source projects,
and they really
will pick whatever
makes the most sense for
their mobile application,
their mobile project.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're saying
that individual developers are
in the driver's
seat, and those are
the people you want to
talk with rather than
their bosses and people
who are running companies?
PASCAL JAILLON: That's right.
Developers, they really
pick their tools.
So you really need to provide
something that adds something
to their toolbox, that really
adds value to the process they
are doing every day.
MARTIN OMANDER: So how do
you build such a product?
If it's not aimed at the
bosses, and you're not
talking about
return on investment
and that sort of marketing, but
you're targeting developers,
that requires you have to build
the product in a different way
too, right?
PASCAL JAILLON: Yes, and
getting the developers really
early on in the process
of building a product
is actually key.
So you need to reach
out to them super-early,
before you even start
developing your product.
And you can reach out to
developers online or offline.
If you are looking at
the online communities,
you will go directly to Twitter,
Stack Overflow, Reddit-- Google
communities.
For us, that was a great
source of feedback.
We engage earlier--
MARTIN OMANDER: Google+?
PASCAL JAILLON: Yeah,
Google+ communities, sorry.
Early on, we engaged
with developers.
We got great feedback.
And that was very important
to iterate with our product.
MARTIN OMANDER:
OK, so that's where
you meet them and
start the conversations
and get their feedback online.
Where do you go to meet
the developers offline?
PASCAL JAILLON: Offline?
Those days your best bet
is really the meet-ups.
Especially here in
the Silicon Valley,
there are a lot of groups
talking on a regular basis
about different topics.
So you pick the ones
that are close to what
you are doing-- the
problems you are addressing
with your product.
And you try first
to attend, to listen
to what's going on there.
And, hopefully,
at some point you
can have a spot to speak
and to present and to,
again, get feedback from
developers about your product.
MARTIN OMANDER: But
when you stand up
there at the meet-up and talk to
developers about your product,
how do you make it
not be a sales pitch?
I mean, you want to
sell your product,
but developers are
allergic to sales pitches.
Even if you provide free pizza,
if there's a sales pitch,
they'll stop coming, right?
How do you thread that needle?
PASCAL JAILLON: That's right.
So you don't want to
be in a sales mode.
You're there, really,
to get feedback.
So the last thing you need
at this point, really,
is dollars-- just feedback.
And there are a
few prerequisites
to get the right feedback
from those developers.
So before you even go there,
make sure that, again, you're
building a strong product,
addressing pain points
that they have, and
then do something
with great experience.
That's key in 2015
to build products
that offer a great
experience for developers.
We're talking about the
developer experience.
It's very important.
MARTIN OMANDER: What do you need
to put in front of developers
at that point for them to be
able to provide this feedback?
PASCAL JAILLON: So you need to
show them APIs, sample code.
You need to show them videos.
Early on, we built some
videos to show them
how to use the product, even
if it was a very early stage
version of the product.
And that's, again,
the best way for them
to quickly learn and adopt it,
and again, provide feedback
to you, which is so
crucial at the early phase.
MARTIN OMANDER: And what
do you do beyond meet-ups?
PASCAL JAILLON: So you can
attend meet-ups, as we did.
But ultimately,
at some point, we
decided also to organize
our own meet-up.
And we focused on the
developer experience
for mobile developers.
And there, again, the best
way to run your own meet-ups
is to not just talk
always about your product.
You have to invite partners.
You have to invite
other developers
to talk about their products.
And, again, at the
end, you end up
sharing about what you're doing.
But it's not just about you.
You also share with
a larger community.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you're
giving more than you're
getting at this point.
PASCAL JAILLON: That's right.
You give a lot.
It's kind of like give,
give, give, and then get.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, is that
about the ratio-- 1 to 3?
PASCAL JAILLON: You need a bit
more gives today in the recipe.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Where does the social media
fit into this whole process?
PASCAL JAILLON: So
the social media
is definitely important
to get feedback
as well because you can
target the local groups here.
But when you build for a niche
market or a smaller audience
that's very targeted,
the social media
allows you to reach out to
developers that you would not
be able to get locally.
So we want the typical Twitter,
Facebook-- Google+ community,
again, was great here.
And what you get is this
ripple effect as well.
While we were still reaching
out to local developers,
at the same time,
for the social media,
we were getting feedback
from Russia, from Australia,
or people in Spain and Italy
finding bugs on GitHub.
Again, so that was really
priceless for us at this point.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right,
because a small startup,
you don't have the
resources to start
physical meet-ups in Spain and
Russia and all these places.
PASCAL JAILLON: That's right.
And the social media
gives you this reach.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Did you approach the Android
and the iOS communities
differently?
I understand your
product works on both.
PASCAL JAILLON: So
we really wanted
to have a product that
offers the same features
for both platforms.
We also realized that
it was much harder
to build this plug-in.
We went with a plug-in
architecture on Xcode and iOS
because it was more like
a closed environment.
So we had to work with
other projects on GitHub
and learn from other
developers that
were doing something similar.
On Android, that
was a bit easier
because it's more documented.
And, also, there are
many more plugins
that we already developed.
So it was an easier process.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
All right, great.
Thank you very much for coming
in and sharing your experiences
with us, Pascal.
PASCAL JAILLON: You're welcome.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]